[Música]
luz verde al acuerdo para Elevar el
techo de la deuda en Estados Unidos con
un total de 314 votos a favor el pleno
de la cámara de representantes aprobó el
proyecto que ahora pasará al senado el
presidente Joe biden lo calificó como
una buena noticia para la economía
estadounidense
amnistía internacional alertó en un
informe sobre la falta de condenas en
Chile por los abusos policiales durante
las protestas de 2019 tan solo 22 de los
más de 10.000 casos un 1% del total han
acabado en condena para amnistía el
estado chileno tiene grandes debilidades
en materia de Derechos Humanos
el rápido desarrollo de las tecnologías
de Inteligencia artificial ha traído
también dilemas sobre su regulación para
ello Estados Unidos y la Unión Europea
lanzarán un código de conducta
voluntario al que esperan que se unan
más países
Bienvenidos a un nuevo informativo de
France 24 dedicado a las principales
noticias del continente americano Mi
nombre es Rodrigo sedano y es un placer
estar con ustedes abrimos en Estados
Unidos la cámara de representantes
aprobó el acuerdo para Elevar el techo
de la deuda el proyecto necesitaba una
mayoría de 218 votos y contó con el
respaldo de un total de 314 a pesar de
los temores que generaba la oposición de
varios congresistas demócratas y
republicanos solo 117 legisladores
votaron en contra el presidente Joe
biden calificó el resultado como una
buena noticia para la economía
estadounidense e instó al senado a
aprobar el proyecto lo antes posible los
detalles desde Washington con nuestro
corresponsal Cristóbal Vázquez la cámara
de representantes de mayoría republicana
aprobó el proyecto para levantar el
techo de la deuda con el 314 votos a
favor y 117
fueron los moderados demócratas y
republicanos los que impulsaron esta
iniciativa que ahora pasa al senado
donde ya analistas legislativos aquí en
el Capitolio dicen que se va
virtualmente a probarlo más pronto
posible dado que la mayoría de El senado
es demócrata de hecho ya se está
considerando el viernes en la noche como
fecha límite para la votación de El
senado y para que este proyecto pase a
la mesa de el presidente biden Para que
se firme como ley y se eviten de Fox
financiero de hecho al respecto el
presidente Joe biden ya reaccionó
diciendo que instaba precisamente al
senado a firmar y aprobar cuanto antes
este proyecto de ley aprobado en la
cámara de representantes y que era un
paso trascendental para evitar este
defod financiero y seguir adelante
seguir avanzando en el rumbo económico
del país analistas políticos también
como una gran Victoria para el
presidente biden esta aprobación esta
mediación y este cabildeo que hizo para
que la cámara de representantes que es
de mayoría republicana haya votado un
proyecto que se negoció entre
republicanos y demócratas entre
legislativo y El Ejecutivo Y estos
seguramente será un argumento de campaña
de cara ambición de reelección en el
2024 también en Estados Unidos según
informaciones avanzadas por la agencia
reuters el vicepresidente de Donald
Trump Mike pence planea anunciar su
candidatura a las primarias del partido
republicano el próximo miércoles de este
modo los dos hombres que trabajaron
conjuntamente en la casa blanca se
enfrentarían por la nominación
republicana una situación que refleja su
confrontación pública recordemos que
Mike pence criticó severamente el rol de
Trump durante el asalto al Capitolio
y el gobierno de Panamá informó que en
lo que va de año un total de
166.122 migrantes cruzaron la selva del
Darién que separa el país de su vecino
Colombia este número es Casi cinco veces
mayor al del mismo periodo en el año
2022 entre los migrantes los venezolanos
son la nacionalidad predominante
seguidos de haitianos y Ecuatorianos
Durante los últimos 15 días se ha visto
un descenso en la cifra de personas
cruzando la selva coincidiendo con el
inicio de la temporada de lluvias que
dificulta la travesía
human Rise watch cuestionó los
comentarios del presidente Luis Ignacio
lulada silvas sobre el gobierno
venezolano durante la Cumbre de líderes
suramericanos en Brasilia el líder
brasileño insinuó que la democracia está
prosperando en el país caribeño y
calificó el debilitamiento de las
instituciones democráticas venezolanas
como una construcción narrativa la
organización dijo que estos comentarios
eran imprudentes y recordó que junto a
otras ong ha documentado violaciones a
los derechos humanos en Venezuela
vamos ahora a Chile donde amnistía
internacional denunció un deficiente
trabajo del gobierno respecto a las
condenas de los casos de abusos
policiales perpetrados durante el
estallido social de 2019 a tres años y
medio de esos incidentes solamente 22 de
los 10.936 expedientes llegaron a una
resolución según indicó la organización
que también agregó que hubo malas
atenciones a las víctimas y nula para
aquellas que viven fuera de la capital
chilena Ramiro cué Barberena nos cuenta
más
luego del estallido Social ocurrido en
Chile en 2019 la organización amnistía
internacional remarcó el deficiente
trabajo de la justicia para condenar los
abusos policiales según publicó en su
informe sólo 22 de los 10.936
expedientes sobre las violaciones de
derechos humanos han tenido una
resolución hubo algunos casos de
homicidios
hubo casos de golpiza muy brutales
personas con lesiones oculares
cientos de personas sobre todo niñas
adolescentes que denunciaron haber sido
desnudadas en unidades policiales
amnistía también remarcó que los
procesos de peritaje de 4.402 casos se
han extendido hasta por dos años después
del ataque y que el gobierno no ha
efectuado las reparaciones necesarias
para las víctimas estos datos que
mostrarían que el panorama general es de
mucha impunidad Por cierto son graves y
muestran que el estado de chile ha
estado in sus obligaciones
internacionales esto ya ha pasado más de
un año desde el inicio del gobierno del
presidente borich tres año y medio desde
el inicio del estallido social y todavía
estamos a la espera de unas políticas
integrales de reparación el reporte
también detalla otras fallas en la
atención a Los afectados como el
tratamiento psicológico y la falta de
atención a las personas que no reciben
en Santiago
en contrapartida el congreso promulgó
recientemente una ley que da mayores
facultades a la policía para utilizar
armas de fuego
en Perú la ley de aeropositora keiko
fujimori no podrá salir del país por 36
meses así lo dictaminó un juez mientras
se le investigan el llamado caso
cócteles keiko está acusada de
presuntamente haber lavado dinero en sus
campañas electorales de 2011 y 2016 la
medida se extiende a su ex esposo y
otras seis personas colaboradoras con su
partido fuerza popular ni keiko ni
Ninguno de los acusados podrán
comunicarse entre ellos o cambiar de
domicilio fiscal sin permiso judicial
Cómo regular el terreno desconocido y en
rápida evolución de la Inteligencia
artificial Esta es la pregunta que se
hacen europeos y estadounidenses al
lanzar un proyecto común un código de
conducta voluntario para esta tecnología
en el que esperan se suscriban otras
democracias veamos de qué se trata en el
informe
Progreso tecnológico para unos y peligro
potencial para otros la Inteligencia
artificial evoluciona a un ritmo
vertiginoso pero la normativa del sector
sigue siendo en gran medida un terreno
inexplorado algo que la Unión Europea y
Estados Unidos intentan cambiar ahora
con un nuevo código de conducta
voluntario
avanzaremos en un borrador de código de
conducta sobre Inteligencia artificial
en las próximas semanas teniendo en
cuenta los comentarios de la industria
los comentarios de los independientes
Europa ha estado avanzando en un marco
jurídico vinculante sobre el sector de
la Inteligencia artificial que
prohibiría la vigilancia biométrica y
garantizaría el control humano de las
tecnologías aunque las normas no
entrarían en vigor sino hasta antes de
2025 Estados Unidos sede de grandes
empresas que desarrollan esta tecnología
como meta Google Amazon y opening ha
acordado un código de conducta con
directrices jurídicamente No vinculantes
creo que compartimos la convicción de el
consejo de comercio y tecnología entre
la Unión Europea y Estados Unidos tiene
un importante papel que desempeñar para
ayudarnos a establecer códigos de
conducta que estén abiertos a todos los
países que lo deseen Estados Unidos y la
Unión Europea esperan conseguir aliados
en el proyecto entre ellos Reino Unido
Canadá e India China también ha debatido
la normativa pero las potencias
occidentales temen que la creciente
destreza de Beijing en este campo y su
voluntad de exportar a otros países
autoritarios pueda establecer normas
mundiales
así cerramos este informativo sigan
conectados a France 24 y France 24.com
[Música]